we are pleased to have in our studio
professor Kreuger Ram Rajan he's the
professor of finance at the shear go
boot School of Business and now the
chief economic adviser to the finish
your finance in India dr. Rajan
welcome to you thank you you have your
presentation at the Jackson Hole meeting
in 2005 has now gone into legend because
two years before the crash you actually
had warned about the possibility of a
high cost crisis coming and also you
pointed out the disc that fund managers
are taking because of the payment system
that they were working under and both
have proven to be absolutely prophetic
now looking back at those years since
2007 till now how do you tell our
audience very briefly as to how has the
u.s. dealt with the crisis how well or
not and how has Europe followed suit in
the crisis well I I think that the US
has dealt certainly with the immediate
consequences of the crisis fairly well
but I think the crisis reflects some
deeper problems in certainly in the u.s.
pearls in Europe Europe has not yet
dealt with the aftermath of the crisis
to some extent because its problems
involved not just problems within the
banking sector but problems that then
infected the government sector and with
no real source of strength in a number
of countries that is that is unaffected
by the crisis they've been having a much
harder time sort of restoring confidence
in growth right if you could go to the
u.s. first just how did the US
government one was the stimulus package
which kind of tried to staunch the
collapse of the economy I I think as
much as the media stimulus package was
certainly the feds willingness to keep
interest rates low early on and the
massive infusion into the banks
essentially first by guaranteeing their
debt second by expanding Deposit
Insurance and third by basically willing
to be being willing to recapitalize
problem banks with tarp overnight
this took away any concerns that the
public may have had about the banking
system I think it was a bowl set of
moves it was the necessary set of moves
however I think that the US has been
less successful in restoring growth
partly because the external environment
has also been very weak with what's
happening in Europe but also partly
because I think that the fundamental
problems are not cyclical so they're not
addressed by more sort of you know
fiscal stimulus or monetary stimulus I
think monetary stimulus early on was
important it's run its course
you know qe2 qe3 I would argue a
relatively ineffective compare qe2 and
qe3 if you could explain to our audience
as to what is this this is simply giving
a lot of money to the system so what the
Fed did initially was cut interest rates
but once you cut nominal interest rates
close to zero you can't cut it any
further
it's it's hard to to maintain
significantly negative nominal interest
is what you're telling people is give me
money I'll give you less back when you
when you demand it so there is an
incentive for people then at that point
to stop investing their money keep it in
cash because cash the worst that can
happen is a zero interest rate is what
you want on it so given that it couldn't
cut interest rates further the Fed
started moving into new territory by
basically saying we're willing to issue
money and buy back bonds so it's
expanding its balance sheet
and essentially the idea is by doing
that it will essentially reduce or
fulfill any demand there is for people
to stay liquid so it's a flood the
market with cash or cash like securities
so that people don't want any more of it
but also by buying back bonds from the
market it will push down long-term
interest rates and so when it pushes
down long-term interest rates given that
most people invest on the basis of
long-term interest rates
it gives firms the willingness to go out
and take big projects so the qe3
basically they are buying back
mortgage-backed securities right which
would have possibly some positive impact
on the housing mark on the housing
market
so qe2 was more general it was an
attempt to bring down long bond rates q3
is more targeted at the at the housing
market and housing interest rates the
problem with both these is that it's not
clear that the people who are refraining
from investment amongst corporations or
the people who are sort of who would
benefit from refinancing the house
haven't done so already so you're
bringing down mortgage interest rates
but they already had close to
historically low levels anybody who
could refinance the house you know had
and what's left are the people who would
want to refinance but aren't able to do
so so there were a number of people
myself included who are saying this is
sort of smoke and mirrors the Fed has
basically run out of bullets what it's
doing is pumping up the stock market and
unless you do some something real
changes on the ground you know what goes
up comes down and comes down with a hard
landing so it's entering dangerous
territory that there are some people
myself included who would like in an a
political world for their fair to say
we've run out of bullets now the problem
is yours and an ultimately problem is
how do you fix
those homeowners were deeply underwater
if you can fix some of that maybe there
is a way out of the situation they're in
but low interest rates doesn't seem to
be the answer for them so apart from
helping out those who are underwater
what else can the federal government do
at this point well I think it can look
for long-term long term structural
change that that leads to growth I mean
one of the biggest concerns about the US
economy is that increasingly it's
creating two kinds of jobs jobs at the
upper end and jobs at the lower end and
many more jobs at the lower end than
jobs at the upper end because they're
just too few people who are skilled
enough to take the jobs at the upper end
ideally you'd want everybody to move to
the upper end and let the lower end work
be done perhaps elsewhere in the world
and that's not happening
because we're not producing enough
people capable of taking jobs in science
technology engineering math which is
where the jobs of the future life
Department reports is at three million
jobs unfilled right essentially because
they are not finding the skills need and
it's not just it's not just engineering
jobs I mean it welders high-tech welders
that's where the jobs are the u.s. is
increasingly creating jobs which are in
capital intensive segments where you've
got this fancy new machine which does it
very quickly very fast but requires a
high order of skill and we don't have
people to do that we have people who can
do well in the old way but that's that
job is migrated yeah so so in a sense we
need to find good ways and I won't argue
that we know of a lot of good ways but
we need to find them of how to get
people the right skills for the jobs
that are being created which means more
partnerships and dialogue between
industry the educators local government
and community organizations yeah to make
this possible
and in as far as the europe is concerned
their problem is a different order the
problems are of a different order faint
resemblance though to that of the u.s. I
mean primarily both I think suffer from
having made tremendous promise in an era
of very strong growth and having to
fulfill those promises promises meaning
social security various kinds of
interest but also death you look at
public debt that's been increasing in
all g7 countries since the mid-1970s not
country by country but on average and
that's suggesting that governments
whenever they had a problem in the past
you say let's spend some more which is
sort of became Xion solution but at some
point you run out of the ability to
spend some more and so not only are the
promises that were made to populations
that are now aging rapidly coming to you
but also the debt that you built up
promising to pay in the future for
current stimulus that's also coming to
you and in your both are coming due at
exactly the same time which is giving
them very little capacity to deal with
the financial sector in the way the u.s.
dealt with it but also is is creating
more problems because they're being
forced to re-examine those promises at a
time of very slow growth which creates
even more public anxieties so there's
already high unemployment yes an on prop
up that people are afraid that they are
not going to get pension are exactly
dusting early car exactly or healthcare
will be cut and so you can imagine the
kind of of worry and anxiety and you
know for those who point to riots in in
Greece or Spain
you wonder why hasn't been higher or
more actually I mean there are worrisome
signs already of right-wing parties
coming in and blaming the foreigner for
for their ills
I mean this is reminiscent of of Europe
in the 30s and you know what hap
then yeah this this Golden Dawn party
exactly they're attacking the migrants
exactly exactly when when you blame your
problems on the migrants that basically
means you've run out of excuses yeah and
and and that I think is a worrisome
state to be in so Asia was not as
affected initially at least by the
crisis and but now it seems the glowing
slowing growth in China India all that
is a kind of wash from this crisis
reaching finally Asia absolutely I mean
the world was in an equilibrium which
was unsustainable they basically
consisted of industrial countries
pumping up growth more than they could
afford through various forms of debt
government debt in in Greece local
government debt private sector borrowing
in Spain Bank Liam you know boring and
lending in the island and an household
boring in the United States yeah in fact
this house one boring you actually have
written in the Foreign Affairs that
because of the competition because of
the level of technology new jobs are not
being created in the US so the
government took the easy path of making
easy credit available to people well I I
would I wouldn't necessarily hang the
blame only on the government but what I
will say is that the environment of easy
credit that we had between 2000 and 2007
approximately nobody had an incentive to
resist it so you don't have to look for
active government measures even the fact
that passively there was no incentive to
constrain it that you could find
politicians cutting ribbons at every
sort of opening of houses and so on
suggested that easy credit was an
environment which everybody liked the
banker because of profits the politician
because his constituents were happy in a
conscience because even though they
didn't see the incomes grow they
certainly could see the consumption grow
and one of my colleagues actually a
couple of my colleagues have written has
written have written this this wonderful
paper on how
you know there was a very strong
incentive to keep up consumption at this
time and the consumption rates in
different sort of areas in the economy
in different geographical areas
increased proportionately to the level
of inequality so if you have a highly
unequal Society some people at the top
consuming a lot you tend to get greater
consumption there great infusion of
credit and eventually greater problems
that's not a sustainable society mm-hmm
so so the inequality that is now a major
issue in the United States was created
to some extent during this period of
credit well growth I would say it was
created before but accentuated next by
the credit fuel growth whose burdens of
unpayable debt and therefore distress
foreclosure is in is ending up on the
people who were initially disadvantaged
anyway in the in their incomes and their
jobs I mean America has a serious
problem of growing polarization the
middle is sort of those jobs are
shrinking in quality and in in
remuneration jobs at either end very low
quality but non-routine jobs
flipping hamburgers in a restaurant
that's increasing in number and very
high quality I think Marc Andreessen the
other day had a very interesting way of
describing it we is the founder he's the
founder of Netscape and he's a venture
capitalist now and he says we're growing
into a society in which one sort of
people tell computers what to do and
they becoming extremely rich and there's
not a set of people whom computers tell
what to do and they're not gonna be
coming particularly that's I think a a
simplification but a very vivid
description of how society is
bifurcating and and clearly we need to
figure out ways to prevent this because
I think a relatively equal society if
not that in outcomes but at least in
opportunities is central to a
good healthy democracy and if we get
that bifurcation we can already see it
in the political polarization I don't
think the polarization is because people
don't don't necessarily see each other
in a rational way it's because their
constituents don't actually want their
political leaders to compromise yeah so
talking about democracy that brings me
to India India the Prime Minister and
the cabinet recently launched this very
important reform one is in FDI in retail
multi-brand retail and also FDI in
aviation and removed at least reduced
the subsidy for diesel now this has been
of course our post very strongly with
opposition parties and the so in a dis
reforms if you could give us a little
background to this reform before we can
go to the question of democracy
well people sort of look at these
reforms and say well they're not
particularly big they're not
particularly significant
so is India still sort of gently sliding
which is which has been the picture
certainly from the growth side and from
other indicators or the last few few
months and you must see this in the
context of what's been happening in
India there has been a certain amount of
political paralysis which has made it
hard to enact the kinds of reforms that
the country certainly needs and amongst
them are a very large and growing
subsidy bill including subsidies to
people who presumably don't really need
it people who own cars yeah don't need a
fuel subsidy SUVs that run on diesel a
series that run on diesel is an
aberration that is particularly sort of
poignant but in general I think the the
concern has been can we start
so moving reforms forward again and I
think the problem in India and this goes
back to our discussion of democracy is
that we had four or five years of growth
without necessarily doing a lot in terms
of new reforms for two reasons one it
was the legacy of past reforms which is
carrying us forward and second the world
economy was doing very well
I think post-crisis the India did sort
of what is natural in these environments
reduce interest rates and expanded
fiscal stimulus and those had the
salutary effect of pumping up growth but
I think as time came to withdraw those
we found that our autonomous growth
without the benefit of a a sort of a
wind of reforms as well as without the
global economy our natural rate of
growth was far lower and in the
meanwhile the budget deficit was growing
very much because all rising in on in
economics you know things happen
together growth falls off your budget
deficit naturally increases because your
ability to text collect taxes reduces
and if at the same time there are other
external effects like rising oil prices
it complicates things even more so I I
think that these reforms have to be seen
in the light of a government which
previously had been paralyzed and so
it's not so much the quantum of these
reforms as the fact that it has been
able to move forward which should be
seen as the big news of course some of
these reforms have the potential to pay
big in the in the in the longer run
especially if we can get a lot of
building of offshore supply chains from
the rural areas to the urban areas I
think that'll be a huge win for India
and connecting bringing more agriculture
to the modern edge bringing agriculture
not just to the modern age but also to
the from the farm to the dinner table
without a huge amount of loss in between
due to waste days due to middlemen
taking up some of the some of the rents
I think that would make it much more
remunerative for the farmer but can also
make the farmer to lots of more
interesting things I mean if you've got
flowers May
grown on the farm they can be made into
bouquets a lot of value addition they
can take place there if you know you can
get it to these same years to the
international markets in short order
that kind of supply chain building is
something that they can happen now one
of the problems in India is we debate
things to depth when maybe the answers
let's try a few experiments and what is
nice about this FBI in retail is clearly
there are arguments against it made by
some people who say oh no what we'll get
is a new set of monopolist who you know
the Walmarts and the targets of the
world will will monopolize the supply
chain and the farmer will not get
anything but now there'll be high prices
but let's see we've opened it up in ten
ten or more states who are willing to
accept the FDI not a bunch of states
just refused and they're a bunch in the
middle so you will have the natural
experiment and my guess is given India's
experience with FDI over the last so
many years never has there been a
situation where FDA has become so
problematic that they've you know
decided to throw the the investors out
yeah in fact initially when India opened
up there was huge opposition but it's
going to believe - tremendous job crises
absolutely I mean the same arguments
that were made against you know opening
up retail were made when we opened up
restaurants Oh McDonald's will wipe out
every small restaurant there is we can't
possibly allow and now you see coexists
perfectly well so I think there's
there's a hype on both sides let's just
open it up and see it's not going to
solve India's problems we can make
things a little better and and that's
really what we should expect and this is
why I keep saying we wait for that
golden reform that wonderful thing which
is gonna change everything in India and
you know for some people it is labor
market reforms for other people never a
mockery for marrying the ability for the
companies to actually hire and fire at
exactly right so the ideas India has too
few
people in unskilled segments of the of
the manufacturing sector simply because
those are sectors where there's a lot of
volatility in demand you get a big order
from from Macy's this year next year
that order disappears well if you build
if you hire a whole bunch of workers to
do the job this year and you don't have
their order next better that those guys
go to the neighboring firm which has
orders from Target or somebody else next
year so what matters is the ability to
ramp up and rain down your workforce
quickly from of courses it's not as
simple as just changing the labor laws I
mean you do need some worker protections
otherwise you could get unlawful yeah
sort of firing and so on and and and of
course that would lead to greater union
militancy and and ultimately you could
have an outcome which is even worse so I
think you need to have some protection
in place some legal system that workers
can appeal to if they find that the
firing is arbitrary and some
compensation structure which says ok
fire but build up unemployment insurance
and things that we need to do all that
so that is a process that needs to take
place but my sense that if we could do
1012 other small things that are pending
and one of the nice things about
developing economies is there are a lot
of low-hanging fruit in luck so just
give us an example of two or three well
one example of a very low hanging fruit
for is for example the requirement that
farmers sell on what is called mundi yes
which is a government controlled market
well there are as if the price is fixed
there the price is is is not so much
fixed as as determined by what some
people argue is a cartel and as a result
a lot of the rents that the farmer could
get is absorbed by the money itself
could you have alternative sort of
avenues for the farmer to sell and then
break the stranglehold of the money i
mean ironically the mundi was set up
initially to protect the farmer but this
has been true of marketing boards a
number of
country so it's something that could be
resolved in relatively short order
another very easy winners lots of big
mega projects held up because of
permissions permissions from petroleum
is from the coal ministry for to mine
coal permission from the Environment
Ministry something different agencies
different agencies each one of them
sitting on the permission sometimes
because the other guy hasn't given it
why should I give it now sometimes
because giving a permission implies sort
of acquiescence yeah and given the
atmosphere in India about a lot of you
know corruption that has sort of is
being discussed and and and on that
there's a great hesitancy on the part of
the bureaucrat to even step a little bit
forward and sometimes these permissions
require you to basically say okay this
rule can never be met nobody has ever
met it we've waived it every time let's
waive it once again but now there's no
willingness to do that Mahalo so this is
this question of corruption the two
issues basically after the sort of
permit Raja was essentially removed the
exploitation of resources underground an
expression of the bandwidth these are
the two areas where the government are
are still in position to give permission
to Anthony's and this has been has
become a source of corruption absolutely
well I I think the benign view is that
our growth was much faster than our
growth of governance I mean one way of
saying one way of describing it is I
know there's not a particularly
expensive sort of raw material and in
fact you know costs were pretty much
close to the returns from from selling
it and so I know our exploitation was
something that you didn't have a lot of
people going after but once the price
rolls in international markets partly
because of the advent of China and so on
into those markets the killing you could
make by just taking the iron ore out of
the ground
in India's abundant in ional and selling
it illegally and pocketing the royalty
is not paying their with tremendous so
these go for corruption increased
tremendously with growth partly because
the governance mechanisms hadn't
adjusted the fact that the resources now
were much more valuable relevant than
they had in the been in the past that
adjustment that now I think is now being
forced on India by the democratic
process and I think that's entirely good
that's one of the virtues of democracy
it's a step stops you from going too far
in any direction and so land grabs being
quelled because the political backlash
of land grabs tremendous of course we've
gone the other way
now you can't acquire land anymore yeah
even if you give the farmer a reasonable
return so we need to work out some
middle ground between acquiring by sort
of violating the rights of the farmer
and acquiring not at all there's some
middle ground and and I think there's a
land acquisition bill which through the
process of negotiation has become a
reasonable one and we should you know
sort of put that out and start acquiring
land according to some rules but but
it's true of every area spectrum we need
better more transparent options they
coming with the 4G auctions that were
done in India were immortal of of
transparency at least thus far
from what we know of it and generated
huge revenues in fact it was because
they generated such significant revenues
that people look back and said whoa we
did some auctions previously yes and and
those weren't particularly successful so
at the our date model was not real
auction was a lot a lot my the first
model was allotment then there was a
free-for-all
you know first in yeah gets it and of
course first in were people who may have
yeah and sighs just the allegation known
when the request for for you know
proposals came the truth in all this is
is something the courts are trying to
find out
and we'll hopefully I mean we have a
good judiciary which over time is also
becoming faster but I think the the
important thing is even while that
discussion is going on can we have a
forward-looking discussion what we need
to allocate these transparently and
fairly and then can we clear the way to
doing this quickly so that these
projects get unstuck
and start that will aid and tremendously
to growth in the short run so the final
question is this the democratic
opposition to the reform to me it seems
like more a political opposition than
really based on facts or even even the
the logic the opposition party like BJP
itself supported FDI in detail in one
stage and now are opposing it for
political reasons so that being the case
do you expect this affirm to carry on
until the next election in 2014 I don't
know about how much political room there
is and and whether the opposition will I
mean that's of any should beyond my
paygrade but I think that there is still
room to do smaller things so are we
gonna have room to do a revolutionary
sort of no those are the kinds of things
that I I would presume elections are
fought on but in terms of steady reforms
growth enhancing reforms I think there's
so many things that you can pick up that
could be done that and this leads to my
reason for optimism about India in the
medium term that the things India needs
for growth in the medium term are just
no brainers getting people off that low
product of the agricultural job into a
high much higher productivity service or
industry job will create growth for the
next 15 to 20 years getting that that
fifth guy in that small 4x4 feed shop
where he's basically employed on
sufferance
he's the nephew of the second yeah of
the brother-in-law of the owner that I
think getting him from there into a good
school into a you know machine shop will
again add tremendously to his
productivity some underemployment and
unemployment in India if we are prepared
to allow change we could we could bring
that down with enormous gains in growth
for the next 2025 years now a lot of
these things can be I should hesitate to
say Lord some of these things can be
done a politically some need political
support especially things that reduce
the budget deficit such as the diesel
prices if not political support at least
a tolerance whereby you say I won't
support it but I want to pose it so do
it because that's the penalty you have
of being the governing party you can't
be responsible but I as the you know non
governing party can can take the high
road and came I would never do these
painful decisions that's fine so long as
you don't oppose it I think if that kind
of modus vivendi can be can be reached I
think there's still a lot that is
possible well on that hopeful not
Prosser Rajan thank you very much for
speaking with us thank you